[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires vous savez
depuis les annonces du président de la
république un certain nombre de
métropoles en france sont entrés dans le
couvre-feu je rappelle les villes
concernées
d'abord les villes de l'île de france
lille grenoble lyon aix marseille
montpellier rouen toulouse et
saint-etienne naturellement bon nombre
de ces villes étaient déjà en zone de
vigilance écarlate ce qui avait entraîné
de nombreuses mesures drastiques vous le
savez pour contrer le retour de cette
deuxième vague fermeture des bars bien
sûr des gymnases des salles de sport
alors comment vit-on la situation dans
ces villes concernées notamment
montpellier et toulouse est bien via
occitane et nos confrères sur place sont
allés voir regarder gagné tostan
terrasse ensemble ici à montpellier
l alerte rouge maximale a été décrétée
pour l'ensemble de la métropole et sept
autres communes aux alentours de
nouvelles mesures restrictives ont été
annoncées par l'état pour faire baisser
le taux d'incidence de lakovic 19 dont
la fermeture des bars pour deux semaines
ça saoule un peu parce qu on se dépacse
aller refermer en octobre alors que bell
les cours la fac le travail les
transports sahara et se trouvait en fait
du coup on fera plus d'apéro d'apéro à
la maison ou deux
tête de restaurants une mesure qui n'est
pas très comprise non plus par ce
responsable de bach lui qui possède
trois établissements avec une année
compliquée financièrement on subit on
subit on subit première fermeture
ensuite interdiction de fermer à 2h
ensuite interdiction de fermer à une
heure est maintenant interdiction totale
d'ouvrir donc voilà on subit on subit on
espère que l'état va nous aider
s'il existe déjà les aides de l'état des
aides supplémentaires sont accordés aux
communes de montpellier-méditerranée
métropole touchés par ces mesures
le maire de montpellier et président de
la métropole dit ne pas minorer la
situation sociale et sanitaire est de
loyer prêt à taux zéro mise en place de
dispositifs autres d'accompagnement je
pense aux salles de cinéma aux lieux
culturels pour faire en sorte
et bien qu'il ne soit pas trop impactées
mais la fermeture des bars est elle
réellement nécessaire pour éviter toute
contamination non répond le président de
toulouse métropole jean luc moudenc son
secteur est lui aussi concerné la
conviction c'est ça depuis le départ
c'est que c'est dans la sphère privée
que le virus se propage pour l'essentiel
la plupart de ces professionnels sont
des gens sérieux
voilà si vous souhaitez aller au
restaurant dans ces zones concernées eh
bien il vous faut y aller avant 21h et
vous soumettre un protocole extrêmement
strictes direction la loi à andrézieux
bouthéon la commune fait partie de la
métropole stéphanoise concernés par ce
couvre-feu et journaliste de tl7 sont
allés à la rencontre d'un restaurateur
pour tester avec lui le nouveau
protocole sanitaire version alerte
maximale regardez il n'y a pas foule ce
midi dans ce restaurant
d'andrézieux-bouthéon qui peut pourtant
accueillir jusqu'à 130 de clients la
crise sanitaire et les nouvelles mesures
pour y faire face ni sont peut-être pas
étrangère sur la partie bar on a moins
moins 100 % et sur la partie
restauration on est de l'ordre de -30%
sur le comparable l'année dernière
l'écart depuis samedi les règles sont
plus strictes
fini les grandes tables et le service au
bar les contrôles eux sont de plus en
plus régulier il y en a déjà eu 2 samedi
et hier des à deux affichages le premier
qui concerne l'enregistrement à la rs
comme on le verra et aussi et surtout
j'ai envie d en priorité le k10 qui
stipule qu'on est bien une activité de
restauration traditionnelle
c'est un des points que présente ce
week-end les services de gendarmerie ont
contrôlé en priorité mais stipule bien
qu'on ait restaurant et pas boîte de
nuit et pas à bar par exemple dans le
quelqu'un on sera obligé de faire des il
ya également deux informations
importantes
la capacité de la salle ici à 132
personnes
elles seront accueillies au maximum et
puis un qr code juste au dessus c'est en
fait le fameux haka y ait de relance qui
sera envoyée à la rs en cas de co vide
parmi elles les clients et bien les
autres qui seront acteurs contacts
seront donc il a rappelé et leurs
données sont sécurisées dans un délai de
14 jours ensuite elles sont
automatiquement détruites
c'est donc pour sécuriser les données de
ses clients que le ninkasi a privilégié
cette solution rassurant et pas
forcément intrusif
selon ce client ça me gêne pas c'est
même utile en fait surtout que nous on
est artisan donc automatiquement si on
n'est qu'à contacter il faut qu'on sache
assez rapidement et on cuisine aussi les
habitudes ont évolué on ne se croise
plus alors mon collègue s'occupe du
montage des salades et des burgers du
côté des salades est
et moi je m'occupe de lancer tout ce qui
est bien depuis son friteuse et j'en
vois quand il a fini ses burgers gens
voient les plages mais les frites dans
les assiettes
un service de vente à emporter a
également été développé avec cette crise
ces deux clients ont opté pour cette
solution ce midi c'était plus simple
plus rapide et pied physiquement on
évitera d'avoir des contacts avec les
gens du coup c'est plutôt cool en cette
période la psy falla d'ici quelques
semaines ce sera je pense
voilà on reviendra avec plaisir et noté
que le ninkasi livre aussi dans un rayon
de 20km au tournant de rayures goûter
voilà le couvre feu va bien entendu
impacté énormément les milieux culturels
et les salles de spectacle la vie de ces
salles étaient déjà très compliquée par
la crise du coït 19 exemple en aux ailes
vous allez le voir la salle de concert
le gueulard plus de nilvange est à
l'arrêt presque totale ces équipes ont à
coeur de repenser son projet culturel
afin de continuer bien sûr à soutenir
artistes et techniciens
un reportage de galles 10 pour vient
moselle tv sur place regarder
[Musique]
sur des notes de jazz et dans une
atmosphère intimiste la scène du
gueulard plus de nilvange reprend vie
pour ce premier concert de la saison le
rhodia spot quartet se produit avec une
invitée de renom la saxophoniste lisa
cat-berro on à communiquer entre nous
avant on s'est envoyé les partitions de
la musique et on a deux jours pour
préparer un concert chaque
instrumentiste a proposé à l'ensemble
d'interpréter deux compositions
personnelles un défi artistique mais
aussi un beau moment de retrouvailles à
des gens moi je me réjouis parce qu'on
va je vais retrouver mes collègues ou
pour jouer en fait pas ce qu'il
adviendra
et puis l'échangé avec le public ça va
être quelque chose de plus je dirais
plus magique que d'habitude car la crise
sanitaire continue d'impacter la scène
culturelle en raison de la coved le
pianiste allemand qui n'a pas pu passer
la frontière a dû être remplacé en
dernière minute quand togolais rpt plus
il a dû revoir sa programmation pour
s'adapter au nouveau protocole la fosse
qui accueille habituellement 360
spectateurs voient sa jauge passer à 150
places assises
alors le style musical du lieu a dû être
repensé forcément on surprend un peu
plus le public qu'on a habituellement
qui est un public de métal de punk de
rock donc normalement il ya de la sueur
il ya des pogos donc là forcément il va
falloir s'adapter à tout ça donc cette
septième saison sera fortement marqué
par du jazz du jazz de la musique du
monde mais aussi trois concert jeune
public rythmeront la saison jusqu'au
mois de décembre il faute de pouvoir
assurer la venue d'artistes
internationaux
la salle a choisi de soutenir plus
encore la production artistique locale
cet artiste là par exemple était en
résidence de création début septembre
donc grâce à cette résidence à va
pouvoir nous présenter un spectacle 21
novembre
malgré les subventions publiques et les
mesures de chômage partiel faute de
billetterie l'équilibré financier de la
salle a été largement mise à mal une
saison compliquée pour toute l'équipe
qui a à coeur de faire revivre ce lieu
nous pour savoir qu'on a fait du bon
boulot c'est de voir le public chanter
crier danser et
là en fait on n'a pas ce remerciement et
c'est assez compliqué moralement mais ce
vendredi les premiers applaudissements
devrait bel et bien réchauffé la salle
et redonner de l'élan à ceux qui la font
vivre
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans
l'actualité
octobre rose c'est le moi est le nom
donné pour sensibiliser les femmes au
cancer du sein
on va se rendre au chu d'amiens
maintenant ou un nouvel appareil de
mammographie a vu le jour et de très
nombreuses patientes sont venus
l'essayer gratuitement d'ailleurs vous
allez le voir
adélaïde bollaert pour la chaîne ou et
aux tv s'est rendu sur place
à 64 ans marie-christine a vaincu son
cancer du sein opéré en 2005 elle est
aujourd'hui en rémission
ce jour elle se rend au service
d'imagerie de la femme du chu d'amiens
picardie pour effectuer sa mammographie
de contrôle annuel
et pour elle réalisé cet examen est
important même si on n'a aucun symptôme
ce qui est pas bien dans la maladie
c'est qu'on a pas mal on ne sait pas
mais il est là si on ne veut pas fait
pas dépister et puis qu'on s'en rend
compte qu'il est trop tard c'est notre
faute à nous l'an maintenant on a tout
ce qu'il faut pour se soigner il faut se
soigner
la mammographie doit être un rendez vous
incontournable dans la vie d'une femme
je vais comprimé
l'examen en lui même n'est pas très
agréable mais les matériels évolué pour
limiter l'inconfort ce nouveau
mammographe par exemple utilise la même
technologie d'imagerie que de scanner la
tomosynthèse qui permet de faire des
coupes virtuelles du sein pour pouvoir
en visualiser toutes les couches
précisément ça nous évite parfois en
fait de faire des clichés
complémentaires et de revenir en salle
et de dire à la patiente et bien voilà
il faut refaire d'autres clichés et ça
génère un stress supplémentaire la
compression de toute façon reste la même
cet appareil est utilisé dans le cadre
du dépistage organisé du cancer du sein
mise en place pour octobre rose est le
but de l'opération est de pouvoir
détecter le plus tôt possible un cancer
pour le traiter au mieux le cancer du
sein se traite bien plus lu ces avancées
plus c'est compliqué plus les
traitements doivent être agressif et on
essaye avec le sain d'avoir le
traitement le plus adapté au stade c'est
à dire à la taille à la gravité est plus
tellement de traiter tout le monde très
agressivement aujourd'hui on meurt
encore du cancer du sein c'est pour ça
qu'on essaye avec le dépistage les
découvrir au stade le plus précoce
possible
il est donc important de continuer à
encourager le dépistage auprès de tous
les publics et surtout pour les femmes
de plus de 50 ans pour elle deux
journées de dépistage gratuit et sans
rendez vous sont organisés les 16 et 26
octobre prochains au chu amiens picardie
voilà presque reportage de wéo la chaîne
de la voix du nord et bien une bonne
nouvelle dans le domaine de la santé
toujours le nombre de fumeurs baisse en
france
une bonne nouvelle pour nous tous mais
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
buralistes qui doivent absolument
transformer leur offre pour survivre un
grand plan de transformation d'ailleurs
est engagée par la profession qui
métamorphose ses enseignes en proposant
de nouveaux services
exemple vous allez le voir à epinal où
les équipes de via vosges ont suivi le
président national de la confédération
des buralistes
en visite sur le terrain regard des
effectifs aussi
j'ai vu des petits bonnets là avec les
pompons pas très joli donc du coup j'ai
regardé j'ai commencé à fouiller puis
non je m'attendais pas du tout dans un
bureau de tabac pour acheter des habits
certes le tabac reste un produit d'appel
suivi des jeux des articles de vva
potager de la presse mais avec des
ventes de cigarettes en baisse et pour
retenir la clientèle
les buralistes ont dû s'adapter aux
nouveaux modes de consommation avec
plaisir pour cette commerçante
spinalienne qui propose dans sa boutique
une offre de services marchands et
public digne d'une liste à la prévert
donc on a les paiements de proximité on
a les pv à on a tout ce qui est cadeau
on a de la bab loterie la maroquinerie
de la décoration on a des habits vous
pouvez trouver des boissons vous pouvez
trouver un petit coupe-faim ci a besoin
de la téléphonie et l'on ajoutera
également la possibilité d'ouvrir un
compte d'obtenir ib carte bancaire en
quelques minutes
pour le président national de la
confédération des buralistes
en visite dans le département samedi
dernier et l'histoire est en marche
il ya quelques années le bureau tabac ne
vendait que de la gitane brune de la
malice du petit gris est arrivé à
cigarettes blondes est arrivé d'autres
marques
et voilà comment une profession évolue
et souvent au détriment du buraliste et
là l'enjeu c'est que ça soit les
buralistes qui crée l'histoire et même
si le confinement a bénéficié aux
buralistes français il se bat toujours
contre la concurrence frontale hier
mais pour le président la priorité c'est
le déploiement du plan de transformation
négocié avec l'état en 2010 est
opérationnel jusque fin 2021 est abondée
de 80 millions d'euros
car valeur maximale est de 33000 euros
par point de vente sachant qu'il y à 30
% globalement de prise en charge sur une
rénovation totale
quelles que soient les éléments et la
modernisation va de pair avec une
nouvelle carotte cet emblème célèbre
obligatoire au fronton
bureau de tabac et pourquoi pas à la
boutonnière des commerçants qui le
souhaitent
on a choisi de ne plus indiquer le mot
tabac par contre on a le petit rappel
bleu blanc rouge
puisqu'on est aussi commerçants services
publics complet pratiquement maintenant
selon la présidente de la chambre
syndicale vosgienne les bureaux de tabac
sont souvent les derniers commerces de
proximité dans un quartier où un village
l'activité selon elle se maintient dans
les vosges avec 158 points de vente un
peu plus de 24000 en france voilà c'est
nouveau dans le grand jt des territoires
nous allons nous intéresser chaque
semaine à une entreprise innovante qui
fait bouger l'économie des territoires
bonjour michel picaud vous présenter le
business club de france des
entrepreneurs une émission diffusée sur
les télés locales de france et vous vous
intéressez donc à l'économie des
territoires vous donner la parole à ces
dirigeants d'entreprise
ceux qui dirigent des pme des start up
qui font bouger l'économie
alors cette semaine ils sont acteurs de
notre relance économique michel qui avez
vous choisi merci de nous accueillir
dans le grand jt des territoires nous
partons à metz pour découvrir très orio
la start up propose des services
informatiques de stockage notamment l
utilise donc des datacenter ces espaces
bardet d'ordinateurs de calcul qui
chauffe qui chauffent beaucoup
il faut donc les climatiser ils ont donc
inventé la première chaudière numérique
ou l'art de récupérer la chaleur de ses
ordinateurs tout en le refroidissant
et cette chaleur se transforme ensuite
en eau chaude pour en faire en chauffage
vert je vous propose d'écouter jonathan
klein dans le reportage devient mozac un
serveur informatique haute performance
dans lesquels on vient poser nous
remplacer les systèmes de
refroidissement par ces blocs de cuivre
on a un circuit à l'intérieur qui permet
de faire voyager l'eau directement là où
sont les puces elle refroidit les puces
et elles ressortent ou chaudes et comme
ses ordinateurs dans les data center ne
s'arrête jamais l'eau est toujours
disponible à 60° voilà une solution qui
existe des hôpitaux font déjà confiance
au chauffage vers inventé par cette
start up et ce n'est qu'un début
voilà merci michel picot nous vous
retrouvons chaque semaine pour nous
montrer ce qu'ils font bouger la france
ceux qui ont la gnac ce qui sont les
acteurs de notre relance économique
voilà nous partons en isère maintenant
dans le grand jt des territoires car la
ville de grenoble a été choisi par
l'union européenne pour devenir la
capitale verte européenne en 2022
vous le savez certainement d'ailleurs le
maire de la ville est un écologiste
réélu aux dernières élections c'est
d'ailleurs la deuxième ville française
après nantes en 2013 à avoir été élu un
titre prestigieux mais pas que toutes
les explications avec ce reportage signé
par nos confrères de tv grenoble sur
place regardez capitale verte européenne
2022 cela fait maintenant plusieurs
années que la ville de grenoble viser
cet objectif sur les 18 candidatures le
jury de la commission européenne avait
choisi quatre finalistes au printemps
2020 turin tallinn dijon et grenoble
chaque année depuis 2008 elle décerne ce
prix à des villans engageons des mesures
dites exemplaire en matière
d'environnement et de développement
durable
une véritable reconnaissance pour le
premier maire écologiste de france d'une
ville de plus de 100000 habitants
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça ça fait
plaisir nous sommes la deuxième ville
seulement seront après stockholm a gagné
dès notre première candidature
d'habitude il ya deux trois candidatures
avant de gagner souvent trois là nous
gagnons dès la première fois c'est aussi
la reconnaissance effectivement d'un
engagement d'une cohérence d'un courage
politique et c'est vrai que dans ces
phases où on est un peu turbulent
chahuté ou parfois le résultat de ces
des élections se retrouvent pas
forcément dans les éléments de
gouvernance parce que on va voir des
situations que politique compliquée il
faut qu'il faut accepter pour départager
les villes candidates la commission
européenne se base sur 12 indicateurs
parmi la qualité de l'air de l'eau la
gestion des déchets les mobilités la
gouvernance ou encore leur capacité à
s'adapter et à atténuer le changement
climatique
grenoble avait alors obtenu les
meilleurs scores première ou deuxième
position sur les onze critères ça ça
peut à la fois nous permettre d'être
fermé finalement de regarder l'avenir
avec ambition est de se dire comment on
amplifie ses transitions comment on va
plus loin
comment on y va plus rapidement comment
on y va surtout avec tout le monde
en prenant ces contributions de tout le
monde
donc c'est un peu un beau moment on aura
un an une grosse année pour préparer ça
et après pour accueillir toute l'europe
ici pour nous inspirer aussi de ce
qu'ils vont venir nous porter comme
message
grenoble succédera à son homologue
finlandaise l'ati qui deviendra en
janvier 2021 capitale verte européenne
avec ce titre la capitale des alpes a
également reçu 350 mille euros pour
mettre en oeuvre ses projets
nous allons revenir maintenant sur ce
grand débat qui n'est un peu partout en
france à propos de l'installation de la
5g
nous partons pour nantes la capitale de
la loire atlantique les opérateurs de
téléphonie test la 5g sur place
l'occasion pour nous de mieux comprendre
cette nouvelle technologie
c'est un reportage signé des équipes de
tv nantes sur place regardez ces
antennes sont presque invisibles et
pourtant elles sont partout autour de
nous en face d'un centre commercial sur
un immeuble d'habitation derrière une
maison
elle abrite désormais la 5g en plus de
sa prédécesseure la 4g
au total 40 antennes nouvelle génération
sont déjà actives à nantes et son
agglomération
objectif affiché par les opérateurs
aller toujours plus vite
on est à la 600 606 megabit en débit
descendant donc c'est le débit qui
servent à quand vous téléchargez quelque
chose par exemple
à titre de comparaison avec la 4g je
suis à 146 mega c'est un des premiers
enjeux de la 5g apporter plus de débit
mais le deuxième qui est largement aussi
important c'est de d'absorber
globalement l'ensemble du trafic data
mobile puisque dans toutes les grandes
agglomérations les études montrent que
d'ici deux ans le réseau 4g va saturer
autre argument massue des opérateurs la
5g
c'est vers la fin j'ai par rapport à la
4g ça consomme dans l'expérimentation
qu'on fait à nantes aujourd'hui ça
consomme deux fois moins d'énergie par
gigaoctet donc quand il ya une
utilisation aujourd'hui pendant huit
minutes d'un utilisateur avec la 5g on
consomme déjà deux fois moins on
consommera dix fois moins à l'horizon
2025 et 30 fois moins
à la fin de la décennie pas convaincant
pour ces militants anti 5 g qui se
réunissent régulièrement à nantes
leur production ce qu'on demande c'est
un débat n'est pas situé contradictoires
on entend quand même monsieur jacob sans
nous dire que cette ça va faciliter la
transition écologique mais ça va nous
faire rire et 30% d'énergie et il ya
tout de même un grand nombre d'experts
qui ne le pense pas du tout a nantes la
mer semble hésiter sur la 5g
elle a demandé un moratoire et pointe du
doigt la précipitation du gouvernement
qui a attribué les fréquences aux
opérateurs avant même l'évaluation des
risques sanitaires pour l'instant le
gouvernement veut accorder les ondes aux
opérateurs au mois de septembre alors
que le rapport sur la santé doit être
remis au mois de janvier
je crois que les choses sont faites dans
le mauvais sens d'abord les informations
et ensuite les décisions en tout cas
annoncé comme ça que nous allons
procéder
orange de son côté se dit prête à
contribuer aux débats mais se plaît à
rappeler que la métropole n'a pas voix
au chapitre juridiquement et bien voici
maintenant un concept qui cartonne
une braderie gratuite ça se passe au
mans son nom la graphie teriya où chacun
donne et prend ce qu'il veut
l'association d'ailleurs
ouanna qui prône le nos déchets n'en
revient pas de ce succès rencontré le
week-end dernier une foule attendait à
l'ouverture du local
diane le moisson pour vyas lmtv sarthe
faisait partie des gens qui attendaient
regarder
depuis l'ouverture du local ce matin la
gratifient ria ne désemplit pas
honnêtement c'est la première fois qu'il
ya autant de monde
il ya eu beaucoup de relais presse mais
aussi un pays qui fait beau et puis
voilà y'a commence à diffuser le message
énonce maintenant y avait cinquante
personnes devant la porte qui attendait
c'était la folie voir ici chacun donne
il prend ce qu'il veut c'est de
l'économie circulaire et le choix est
varié les affaires de divers des plus
d'ordre c'est pas tellement c'est pas
que pour moi les lives des choses à
pâtisserie oui je recherchais et des
vêtements va un petit peu aussi donc je
trouve ça bien pour les gens qui n'ont
pas forcément les moyens comme moi par
exemple au lieu d'acheter ça à prix d'or
au magasin balla c'est gratuit donc ça
donne une seconde vie pour quelqu'un
d'autre
elle apporte à l'aïs s'explique et ré
explique encore le principe c'est que le
concept de gratuité n'est pas répandue
et nombreux sont ceux qui ne comprennent
tout simplement pas voici une bonne idée
mais je vois pas l'intérêt c'est quoi ça
c'est un genre de secours c'est pas le
secours catholique c'est pas c'est une
réorganisation qui distribue
bénévolement et on n'a pas l'habitude de
la gratuité 1 à l'habitude de l' échange
d'argent mais pas de la gratuité donc
les gens osent pas trop prendre et en
impression un peu de volée mêlant l'idée
c'est que tout est gratuit vraiment en
fait ya énormément de dons mais il ya
aussi des gens qui repartent avec des
sacs entiers donc en fait voilà c'est ça
tourne toute la journée
un travail bénévole pour la fondatrice
des couennes a qui n'en retirent aucun
bénéfice les restes de cette gratifia
seront dispatchés auprès de plusieurs
associations ou resserviront lors d'une
prochaine gratuit feria elle sera
courant novembre
information sur la page facebook des
clubs est tout à fait autre chose
maintenant direction la bretagne avec la
pêche à la coquille saint jacques c'est
l'ouverture de la saison comment la
pêche au thon dans le fleuve de la rance
et bien en plonge pour la récupérer
c'est ce qu'ont fait les équipes de thé
vert dont correspondant à rennes
regarder
ce midi la pêche a été plutôt bonne pour
ces deux plongeurs après trois heures
passées sous l'eau ils reviennent taquet
avec 200 kilos de coquilles
saint-jacques taïz et qualité sont au
rendez vous pour ces mollusques pondu il
y a deux ans donc on se retrouve avec un
stock est plutôt conséquent sachant que
ce stock là en taille moyenne c'est des
coquilles saint-jacques ils doivent être
entre 10 et 11 cm nous on travaille des
coquilles un petit peu au dessus donc
pour nous ça va pas changer grand chose
qui est beaucoup plus de volume cette
année car ici c'est à la main que les
plongeurs ramasser les coquilles un
travail de longue haleine qui peut-être
aussi compromis par les conditions
climatiques
des fois c'est un peu plus compliqué de
faire le quota ça dépend des conditions
de de temps et aussi de la nature bits
et enfin de la couleur de l'eau quand
l'eau est trop et trop sale compte ya
beaucoup de particules en suspension
c'est beaucoup plus difficile le péché
voir c'est même impossible dans certains
cas parce qu'on voit pas et c'est vrai
que nous notre premier outil c'est nos
yeux dans ce gisement du fleuve
la pêche est ouverte uniquement du lundi
au vendredi il faudra attendre début
décembre pour l'ouverture des récoltes
en pleine mer voilà et puis signalons
cette semaine le magazine le point et
son édition spéciale lyon toujours
dirigée par jérôme cordelier
regardez cette une lyon on arrête avec
les bêtises point d'interrogation
de nombreux sujets sont abordés dans
cette édition spéciale le cri d'alarmé
des indépendants dans le domaine
culturel
vélorution également c'est un sujet
prioritaire à lyon la politique de
transport fait déjà des mécontents avec
la chasse à la voiture qui est ouverte
et puis l'insécurité avec le grand
ras-le-bol des lyonnais
le nouveau maire grégory douce est élu
aux dernières élections est très
attendue sur ce sujet sensible
voilà la une du magazine le point
spécial lyon avec ce titre évocateur on
arrête les bêtises point d'interrogation
fin de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivi sur l'ensemble des télévisions
locales de france et sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous et
bon courage
[Musique]